ten years ago ayad al-garib was working
for the syrian
intelligence services now he's starting
a lengthy prison sentence in germany
the prosecution said that in 2011 he
knowingly brought dozens of protesters
to a notorious jail
outside damascus to be tortured his
defense lawyer said he feared being
punished himself
if he refused to carry out his orders
the court in koblenz
rejected that convicting him and jailing
him for four and a half years this is
the estate
this is the first step the road to
justice is long and one of the goals is
to bring bashar al-assad in his inner
circle before a court
this is a relief but it's also not the
end it's only the beginning
this is the first trial of alleged
atrocities carried out by the forces of
president bashar al-assad
as such lawyers for the victims in this
case hope it will set a precedent
what's important is we have a verdict
that crimes by the assad government in
the secret prisons
are crimes against humanity this is the
first verdict worldwide
a view that seems to be shared by many
in government in berlin
another element that distinguishes this
case is that the german justice system
has prosecuted
convicted and punished a non-german
whose victims were not german
for crimes that were committed outside
germany
in doing so prosecutors have invoked the
principle of universal jurisdiction for
such
serious crimes
trials outside syria are a glimmer of
hope but also a clear signal to victims
that we and the international community
recognize
it's an issue which not only concerns
germany but many of our partners too
the signal to victims is that justice
will be done
ayad al-garib stood trial alongside
another former member of the assad
forces
both men had left syria and come to
germany as refugees
the second man anwar raslan was a senior
intelligence officer in 2011.
he's accused of multiple murder rape
torture and other
serious offenses he denies the charges
and his case continues
dominic kane al jazeera berlin